let's pull up this uh this tweet here we
got from the oversight committee
republicans breaking we've released
never before seen emails showing dr
fauci may have concealed information
about covet 19 originating from the
wuhan lab and intentionally downplayed
the lab leak theory i gotta say all of
this coming out at the same time is kind
of insane it's after christmas
everyone's fed up my family was done
with it over christmas they could be
burning fouchy uh fauci is again sort of
a conduit in the middle player to a lot
of other bigger players and and also has
a lot of communications with other
individuals that are named to mr gates
but that's a whole different story to
say itself but i think the question is
is this a psyop is an important one
especially when we're having so much
information come out i think we're at a
very important turning point i think a
lot of things are going to change within
the next month within the next two
months i think it's important to look
out and i think this could be also an
attempt to
release a lot of this information to
save their buttocks uh family-friendly
show here
to to to sustain to kind of uh soften
their fall from the the grace of of
covet overlords many people have pointed
out the democrats aren't going to win if
they're running on covet lockdowns yeah
the polling is not going to be in their
favor right now everything's turning
like you know in canada where i'm from
is
you can see it people are so fed up like
there there has to be a turn here and i
think that's what we're seeing maybe
this gives the democratic uh party and
the establishment an out jake tapper oh
oh i can't believe that these numbers
can you believe it i'm on your side i'm
angry too and then all of a sudden
democrats are like we know fouchy let us
down vote for us yeah i saw a tweet
today i was this lady was like all the
lies are coming out you know
everything's being revealed and i was
like no lady these democrats have a 2022
midterm to drag out they need to fix
this now and they're just now realizing
they're a little bit slow but they're
they're on the case now so so this this
document release from the the oversight
committee
uh let me let me read a little bit for
you they say we write to requ request a
transcribed interview of dr anthony
fauci director u.s national
we get it um
enclosed reveal that dr fauci warned of
two things the potential that covet 19
leaked from the wuhan institute of
virology in two the possibility that the
virus was intentionally genetically
manipulated it is imperative we
investigate if this information was
conveyed to the rest of the government
and whether the information would have
changed the us response to the pandemic
so fauci had apparently excerpts they
say excerpts of emails we are making
public today reveal reveal that
information uh fauci
as we as we uh um we learned with the
fouchy leaks remember that
anthony fauci was communicating with
several individuals and they were
questioning whether or not this did come
from a land that's why i mentioned peter
navarro
he had stated that when he was in the
trump administration and they had fouchy
there and they're like what's going on
fauci did not tell them
that they believed it was possible that
the lab leak happened i think at this
point
we may not have an official from the
wuhan lab because you never will because
it's china coming out and definitively
saying yes it happened but i think when
jon stewart rants on colbert's show that
there's no other reasonable explanation
then we're already at that point right
it is it is likely a lab league now
here's where it's fascinating when rand
paul
said that fauci was responsible for this
and then he said i have no
responsibility for this and it's it's
just crazy because
who are they still trying to convince
right at this point
most i think yes most people will be
like yeah i probably came from that lab
john stewart said it right they're
probably trying to convince the people
that own fouchy bobbleheads
yes that's a that's a that's a good way
to describe them
what do you call those kind of
individuals i don't know bobbleheads
that's another that's another reason but
but you know
there's a lot of information coming
forward right now why did you think of
facts
first thing
there's a lot of crazy mind that's
actually a really good way to identify
like i almost got you one dude i'm gonna
get you really yeah no like you can
actually buy dr fauci bobbleheads the
kind of person who has this yes or like
those candles those votive candles oh
yeah where it was like st oh geez
oh my gosh
he'd be a great guest i don't know if
he'd actually say anything if he'd just
be defensive you could even get him or
he wouldn't
i think from today's hearings especially
with u.s senator rand paul it's pretty
clear that fauci is not used to being
asked any tough questions he was
hammered by rand paul i believe
correctly so on on very important issues
on a lot of these emails on a lot of
these documents and dr fauci's response
was it's not true there's people that
don't like me and threaten me i mean
does he know he's talking to rand paul
who literally was attacked by his
neighbor who was literally shot at like
like that was his argument that's not an
argument dr fauci lay out your argument
present the data present your
information and be able to reach across
the aisle and talk to the other side he
has never done that he only does
softball interviews where the pundits
literally
family friendly show
do adult things to him with their uh
mouth
all right all right that's too much hey
i'm definitely
i'm not i'm not going there but but
it didn't uh i didn't see it but you
mentioned crowder yeah
yeah so right at the end of his like
publicly available show he mentioned
that we've been swatted more than fouchy
has like tim pool's been swatted more
than you have complaining i appreciate
the shout out
i think it's pretty clear when dr fauci
is on the corporate media which he loves
to be on he always gets gets softball
question he always gets massage he
always gets fouchy why are you so great
and awesome and and super incredible and
helping save the world that's literally
the type of questions that he can ask
they answer questions for him too
they'll say things like i was curious
your position on the virus because a
bunch of right wing channels were lying
by saying x y and z and of course we
know a b and c so
uh would you like to reiterate what i
just said dr fauci yes that's absolutely
correct the droplets and the masks
exactly and i i think today's hearings
prove that there wasn't any kind of real
discussion it was very testy and i think
it's pretty clear from everyone watching
that dr fauci doesn't have an argument
here and he's definitely on the wrong
side of the larger debate that's
unfolding right now with what a lot of
people are thinking and we're afraid to
express but now it's finally coming out
to the limelight as of course everything
that's being exposed right now the
supposed conspiracy theorists were
literally saying from the very beginning
of this they were censored on big tech
social media they were denied having a
voice in this conversation and now those
conspiracy theorists were really just
spoiler alerts as of course everything's
coming true so in my 1pm segment i
opened with a princess bride reference i
love that it actually it actually was
hard for me to get right i had to try
recording like 10 times
i opened with fauci fell victim to one
of the classic blunders the most famous
of which is never get involved in a land
war in asia and only slightly i see
that's a good one slightly less
well-known is never hold up a piece of
paper on television because you will
become a meme amazing you see i couldn't
even do it right now after all that
practice
but that's that's actually one of the
funniest takeaways from this from that
moment fauci actually picked up a piece
of paper which i will not do and it said
it it's a picture of him and it says
fire fouchy and he's pointing at it
angrily and i'm like yes
yes we agree
thank you for this for this um pantomime
of what we all should do but it was
funny too because it was rand paul's
website
which is fundraising and he was like it
says fire fouchy and you can give one
dollar two dollars five i'm like this is
a great pitch
like he's advertising for it so i i
don't know the whole thing was just
ridiculous but what i love about fauci's
responses to rand paul
is the way i describe it is he's like
rand paul goes
dr fauci you were were engaging in gain
of function research at the wuhan
institute through funding equal health
alliance and fouch you'll be like no we
did not er the the example i give is
like fauci's explanati is rand paul says
you put a door in my bedroom in fact
it's not a door it's just a large piece
of wood on hinges with a knob that when
you turn moves a piece of metal which
allows you to open on the hinges and
enter the room and you're like bro
you're describing a door to me that's
how he does the gain of function it is
not getting the function research it is
just the creation of chimeric viruses to
increase transmissibility
you're describing gain of function dr
fauci no i'm not that's literally what
he did that's crazy yeah i want i think
this guy should be arrested i'm not even
kidding absolutely
subpoenaed uh questioned thoroughly
release all the documents release all
the studies that he's done and when you
truly find out what he's been
responsible for there's no going back to
the official narrative that he has set
on the american people because you learn
about things like robert f kennedy jr in
his book the real anthony fauci talking
about how people were horribly affected
by his studies whether it was orphans
whether it was monkeys whether it was
beagle puppies there's there's a long
trail of just horrible misdoings by this
man and i think it's more than time than
ever that we hold them responsible for
all those actions y'all i want to buy a
bobblehead oh yeah let's get a bunch of
them let's get different ones if we can
find them
because it's energy inviting the devil
into the house but that's hilarious it
is funny like you know we'd have it for
the opposite reason that they would we
gotta get kyrie irving bobblehead too i
mean that's kind of cool though yeah
yeah
yeah he's a hustler yeah first of all
he'll be funny yeah yeah they let him
play again yeah he's playing i love him
the money was more important than the
pandemic i guess they couldn't have
enough players because the test the
players that were vaccinated kept
getting coveted
and they had to bring in the
unvaccinated players and this is not
just happening with sports ball teams
this is happening in hospitals this is
happening in supermarkets there's even
official government notices saying hey
if you test positive just show up to
work anyway literally there's
supermarkets telling people to do this
because of the staff and labor shortages
in major institutions and and we're at a
point in this pandemic where the the
unvacs can't get work the sick that are
testing positive are told to go back to
work that's absolutely crazy it's
actually very very normal because this
was only supposed to be 15 days to slow
the spread anyway you're not supposed to
shut down the economy and this is the
economy like gasping for air like we
can't survive if we don't bring in
anyone
that may or may not have it doesn't
matter at this point because our
survivability is more important it's
like when you said people were climbing
out of the bomb shelters even when the
bombs kept dropping bro you got to get
back to life at some point yeah so uh
last night mike rowe uh pointed out
in the uk during what was the blitz
bombing of london the bombing of london
after a few days people were like okay
the bombs are still going off i guess
it's time to get back to work because
you couldn't just stay locked in your
basement you would just wither away so
even with what they were using zeppelins
right yeah the germans were like they
were using zeppelins for sure for
observation i don't know if they were
dropping bombs from zeppelin but they
were dropping bombs on london people
were like back to work and bombs are
going off stay calm carry on i think
we're at that point are they getting
rocketed i think we're at the point
where hospitals are just like okay we
can't function anymore just bring back
the nurses bring back the unvax nurses
burn back kyrie irving bring back thank
god man
that's the natural i mean the natural
flow of any of any disease anyway of any
epidemic is eventually get back to it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time